[Musique]
pour le cssa je pense que c'est pareil
que pour les autres salles
malheureusement je reconnais tous logés
à la même enseigne
les petits les moyens les gros je parle
je parle de la taille des exploitations
c'est très très très difficile nous en
ce qui nous concerne on était à -68 on
est à -65 donc on va dire que ça
s'améliore un petit peu je rassure tout
le monde il ya un protocole sanitaire
qui est appliqué leurs aînés renouvelle
dans les salles le masque est
obligatoire maintenant pendant toute la
projection on peut se dire que c'est
handicapant mais pour l'avoir
expérimenté à plusieurs reprises the
pardon ça va c'est supportable
on peut regarder un film avec un masque
quand le film est bon on oublie le
masque je pense que avec une offre qui
va s'étoffer quand même un petit peu
d'ici à la fin de l'année une offre de
films le temps qui va nous aider aussi
puisque on rentre dans l'automne on va
rentrer dans l'hiver et cetera
s'il n'y a pas une catastrophe au niveau
sanitaire ce qui évidemment personne ne
souhaite
je pense que le public va revenir dans
les salles progressivement il va y avoir
les vacances là aussi de de la toussaint
donc en général assez forte période de
fréquentation elle sera bien sûr
inférieur aux années précédentes on vit
on vit une année de toute façon
tellement spécial